on the phone and now via social media
this is where vladimir putin responds to
average concerns
albeit pre-screened ones from the price
of vegetables
to covert 19. with russia in the grips
of another major wave of coronavirus
infections
putin was eager to dispel fears around
russia's sputnik vaccine
the country was quick to develop the jab
but only 15 percent of russians have
received a dose
until now the kremlin had refused to say
which vaccine
putin had received worsening public
confidence in the russian jab
i thought that i needed to be protected
as long as possible
so i chose to be vaccinated with the
sputnik vaccine
the military is getting vaccinated with
it and after all i'm the
commander-in-chief
putin's left many pandemic decisions to
regional officials
some areas including moscow have decided
to make vaccinations mandatory for
millions of workers
officials say people can decline workers
fear they'll be fired if they do
putin meanwhile revealed he doesn't
support mandatory jabs
the virus has challenged his popularity
but on tensions with the west
a more characteristic leader was on show
he mocked the united states pressing an
imaginary button on his forehead
to show how american officials activate
their brains
he went on to accuse the british navy
along with u.s air support
of provocation by sailing knowingly
close to crimea part of ukraine
but seized by russia in 2014 the russian
military responded by firing warning
shots and dropping bombs in the british
ship's path
what was even if we sunk this ship
it would be difficult to imagine the
world would be on the verge of a third
world war because those who do it
know that they can't emerge victorious
from this war
despite stagnating wages and falling
living standards
putin's approval at home is still high
but steps to quash opposition political
movements
including that of alexi navalny have
pushed the leader further into
international isolation
meanwhile the longest-serving russian
leader since joseph stalin
shows no sign of retiring the time will
come he said
when i will name my possible successor
nevaka al jazeera